what do you make of the derision from
the skeptics and maybe even scientists
who say well i only follow the data and
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence what's your
response to those statements
um
well my response is well that's if
that's how you want to operate stay in
the caves i'm interested in leaving the
caves and going out um into uncharted
territory
and uh
you know the the the derision comes i
think
from people thinking that a conclusion
has been made
no conclusion has been made and explain
a potential explanation
for
the data has been offered
and even when you publish a paper
everybody knows that when you publish a
paper and you state the conclusions
you are stating a formulation of the
observations at a moment in time fully
well realizing that 10 years from now or
20 years from now what you thought was x
y and z
is actually part of a larger framework
in picture
that uh you can look back and say well
that's not quite the way to look at it
here's how you would think about how
this is operating so papers are although
people like to think
are scientists saying this is how things
are
even though it comes across that way
often in papers it really is just a
moment in time
that you're planning a flag and you're
going to say okay 10 20 years from now
we might reformulate because new data
has arrived which allows us to put
things in a into a bigger picture
i mean you know this from from
physics you know maxwell's equations on
you know on electricity and uh
and magnetism
um
you know there are formulations of those
these days that
show that you know there's a form of
quantum physics that actually inc that
you can that maxwell's equations fall
out of
but it's a larger the
quantum
the quantum equations are a larger
uh picture of reality
and that
the maxwell's equations are just a piece
of them that fall out of it
um
and uh
and so
the critics actually don't bother me
they you know if anything they make
themselves out to be
uh you know
obviously less informed
and it's not my job to convince
the critics in my opinion my job is just
to do the science and get the data out
there and say this data is real
now
you help me figure out what it is that
it means
and when data comes out that shows that
something is not what they want it to be
i've i'll be right there in fact if
anything i have disproven more things in
this field
than i've been i have proven to date
you know the atacama the stark house
skull
and a couple of these so-called events
it sounds like you're saying look i
haven't come to conclusions
in fact what you're doing as the
quote-unquote skeptic is coming to a
non-conclusion by saying so-and-so is
not possible or then they may modify and
say well i'm saying so-and-so is not
probable but then the way that i like to
view that is well not like to view that
there's a problem that i can't solve
which is called the reference class
problem which if anyone studies
statistics this comes up it's that
how do you know the probability of some
event so for example if i was to say
well what's the probability that you're
going to die this year and then you can
say well
well it's actually
100 it's 99 and then i say why then you
say well if you look at all the life
forms on the planet
most of them are going to die in the
next year because most of them continue
right so why are you choosing that as
your reference class so you'd say okay
okay okay so then when someone says well
aliens and so-and-so are now
extraterrestrial beings or so-and-so are
not possible they're choosing from a
certain reference class and that i don't
know how one justifies that
so even claims of probability that
so-and-so is more profitable or less
probable they're dubious to me
well the the one that always gets me
that just is
shows me
how some of the skeptics are almost
knee-jerk about it is this notion that
well if they came from another star
system
um it would have taken them thousands of
years to get here
all right well okay i have two solutions
to that one it's a very old universe
um
two
well and in that there's plenty of time
for somebody have to have come here even
by simply conventional means and that
doesn't mean that
the people who created the craft
that got here are the ones that are here
you know if you're advanced enough to be
able to create your own ai
right i mean there's the whole concept
of the von neumann machines
you know this one right the von neumann
machine idea
that you know something arrives makes
more copies of itself
sends those copies off elsewhere and
basically there's this exponential uh
reach
even across you know across galaxies
and what's to say that when such an
object
arrives it doesn't construct from
base
processes
uh an egg
that then is then turned into uh
whatever it is that the von neumann
machine is meant to make and then
you know i mean there have been plenty
of science fiction stories written about
this that and when they get there the ai
then teaches the humans what it is to be
a human right there's um there's
actually one that's just on netflix
right now raised by wolves
uh it's a british show i think
um it's pretty good
so i mean that's that's one of them and
then second
it it assumes that we know everything
about the laws of physics
right this notion that okay well they
are somehow
as you in your terminology they are
bound by our reference frame
and uh
that are our reference is
uh the current laws of understanding of
you know e equals m c squared
uh and you know somebody else has
different math
right and so if one was going by
if one was choosing the reference class
to be well look every 60 years or so in
physics our formulation of physics is
drastically overturned or let's say
every 80 years or so then and we're
assuming these beings if they're beings
are far greater than 80 years ahead of
us well right we impose that they have
the same understanding of physics
also it's false to say that from the
nearest star system it takes thousands
of years to come to us they can come to
us or someone can come to us with
special relativity almost
instantaneously it's just that thousands
of as far as they're concerned right
right in their reference frame right